- I’m waiting for my invitation for the wedding.
- [Laughing]
- Oh, my God!
- I’m gonna be, I’m gonna be invited, or no?
- Yes, one day if there’s a wedding—
- One day, right?
- Between this lovely woman and I, you will be invited.
See what I did there, guys?
- [Laughing]
- [Serge:] That’s a good one.
What’s up, babyyyy?
This is Serge Ibaka, aka Mafuzzy Chef.
Welcome to “How Hungry Are You?”
So today, I will be cooking for
Karrueche Tran and Victor Cruz, Salsa Man.
- I saved my appetite for Serge,
but I’m a little nervous because I
know he be cookin’ some wild s--t.
- Karrueche is on the TV show “Claws,”
so today, I’m cooking alligator claws.
[Laughing offscreen]
♪♪♪
- [Offscreen:] All right, so let’s everybody
get in position. Let’s get cameras up.
- [Serge Ibaka:] Showtime, like always.
Now it’s time to boil alligator claws.
Ten minutes!
Look at those nails. They look nice.
To make things smooth,
always use a little bit more extra.
- [Karrueche:] Well, I don’t eat
pork and I don’t eat red meat,
so, like, what could it be?
And if it’s anything too crazy,
I probably won’t eat it.
- He's a very good boy.
Marcus, where’d you get your claws?
- [Marcus:] Chinatown.
- Chinatown?
- [Marcus:] Yeah.
- That was pretty easy?
- Real easy.
- Wow! I mean, this is a good meat, bro.
- [Karrueche:] But I just hope it’s not, like,
cow testicles or, like, I don’t know.
Does he cook that kinda stuff?
- [Offscreen:] Yes, he does.
- Ahhh.
- [Serge:] Hey! What’s up, what’s up?
- [Karrueche:] What’s up?
- [Serge:] Good to see you.
- [Karrueche:] Good to see you as well.
Where’s Vic, actually?
- [Karrueche:] He’s coming.
- He’s supposed to be here, right?
- Yeah, he’s coming soon.
- OK, so you can be here, Vic’s gonna be there.
- He’s fashionably late.
- Thanks for having me.
- How you been?
Things been good?
- Great. I’m a little nervous.
OK, right here?
- You can get the fruits here.
- [Karrueche:] OK.
- And which one you prefer?
This one or this one?
- This is, like, my size—this is, this is me.
That’s, that’s you. That’s our height difference.
- So how did you come from
being a stylist, a model—
to the movie?
- I had a very small role in this horror film.
And so from there,
I just started taking acting classes,
working with a coach.
And then—here we are.
- It was kinda hard in the beginning?
- Oh, my God, yes.
I went on a lot of auditions
and was told “No.”
- No?
- Many a time.
- How many times?
- [Scoffing] A million times.
And something in my head told me, like—
- Don’t give up.
- “Don’t give up. You’ll—you got this.”
Um—
- [Offscreen:] Hold up for a sec.
[Offscreen:] That’s enough fruit, just
so you guys have more eye contact.
- [Karrueche:] Oh, OK.
- [Serge:] Yeah.
- I take this very seriously, you guys.
- OK, yeah, but she—
- But I did it!
- [Offscreen:] That’s good.
- [Serge:] Hey, it’s Victor.
- Oh, he’s here!
[Laughing]
- [Serge:] Ahhh. Victor, take a seat.
We’ll get to you in a minute.
- I’ve known Victor for a long time.
- Yes.
- He’s into fashion too.
- [Karrueche:] Oh, yeah.
- How do you think about my
style, what I can change?
Tell me something about Serge, like—
what do you think I
need to change in my style?
- Do you have a designer that you
work with that makes specific—
- You know, it’s, it’s hard for tall guys.
- Right, because I was gonna say,
I feel like sometimes—
- Yeah?
- Your pants might be a lil’ high.
- A little high?!
- A little high-waterish…
- What do you mean “high-waterish”?
- Like,
your ankles are showin’ too much.
Like, they’re not long enough.
- [Serge:] Not long enough?
- [Karrueche:] No!
- Look, Victor. Look what kinda pants he’s wearing!
- [Laughing]
- No, but that’s, that’s supposed to be like that.
- [Victor:] This is stylish, Serge.
- Since my guy Victor is here: Victor! Come on, bro.
- [Victor]: I’m in?
- [Serge:] Yes, sir. You’re in, baby.
- [Victor:] All right.
- [Karrueche:] Bring that ass over here.
- What’s this “Mafuzzy Chef” about?
- Yes, sir. That’s me.
- [Victor:] That’s you?
- How do you say that? Muh-fuzzy, muh-foozie?
- How do you say it?
- [Karrueche:] Ma-fuzzy?
- [Serge:] OK, you go first.
- Muh-fuzzy.
- [Serge:] OK.
- Muh-foozie.
- Oh—
- You good. You see—
- Yeahhh.
- I know you. You original, bro.
- Been around you for a minute!
- I saw you dancing salsa.
-  I already know!
- You original, bro.
You really can dance like that?
- I’m Puerto Rican. I grew up dancin’ with my grandmothers.
- Show him what you can do.
- No, we not gonna do that today!
- Not doing that.
You can dance—like, he dance with you
sometimes, when you guys go out and salsa?
- When I’ve had enough drinks in me, we dance.
But I don’t salsa. I just—I don’t know how to—
- Don’t salsa?
- I’m tryna get her—
- You gotta have that hip movement
- I’m gonna get her to salsa.
- and stuff, and I ain’t got that.
- [Serge:] Let’s get her to salsa, bro.
- That’s my one mission—and
I’m looking directly to the camera—
that’s my one mission in life is to get this woman to salsa.
- [Serge:] You have to, bro.
- Can you salsa?
- Me?
- Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
- I’m, I’m original man.
- [Victor:] Oooh.
- [Karrueche:] So what does—
yes? What does that mean?
- [Serge:] Now, listen.
- [Victor:] Mafuzzy Chef?
You think Mafuzzy Chef doesn’t know how to salsa?!
- [Serge:] Mafuzzy Chef.
Come on.
- [Karrueche:] Ma-fuzzy.
- Ma-fuzzy Chef.
- [Serge:] Ma-fuzzy, no.
Muh-foozie.
- Ma-fuzzy.
- Of course I know how to do salsa.
- [Offscreen:] You could show her.
- Hey! You’re turnin’—
- [Serge:] What do you think?
- [Victor:] There you go. Serge got it!
- [Serge:] What do you think, Victor?
- He got the elbow move and everything.
- All right, you got some hips.
- [Victor:] We good.
- [Serge:] Exactly.
- All right, all right, Ma-fuzzy.
- [Serge:] You approve, or no?
- So, you know, I’m waiting for
my invitation for the wedding.
- [Karrueche:] Oh, my God!
- [Victor:] [Laughing]
- I’m gonna be, I’m gonna be invited or no?
I’m coming or no?
- Will you be invited?
- [Serge:] Yeah, I’m asking.
- Yes, one day if there’s a wedding—
- [Serge:] One day, right?
- Between this lovely woman and I, you will be invited.
See what I did there, guys? See how I played that?
[Laughing]
- That’s a good one.
- See what I did there?
[Sizzling]
- [Serge:] Tell me a little bit about your movie,
“Shark Attack.” The shark one.
- You looked that up?
- Yeah.
- [Karrueche:] Why?
- It’s a great movie, by the way.
- You didn’t, you didn’t watch—
- [Serge:] It’s funny, bro.
- [Victor:] I watched it.
- You watched it?
- The shark with three heads?
- [Karrueche:] Three heads.
- [Victor:] Three heads.
- [Serge:] Oh, my God.
- Listen, this was a—
- I’ve never seen something like that before.
[Laughing]
How did that happen? Like, everything?
- CGI, obviously.  It's not real.
- OK.
I know, but it looked—
- That was—it looked—
- [Serge:] You go ahead.
- [Karrueche:] It looked real?
You know that did not look real!
- [Serge:] Victor, tell me about it.
What do you think about it? Be honest, please.
- Well, there was a scene in the movie
where they were all standin’ by the beach.
- [Serge:] Yeah.
- Right?
- OK, yeah.
- And they were like, “Man, there’s no
way the shark’s gonna come up here.
There’s no way.” And that thing came
ashore with three heads and
bit, like, three people, and everybody else ran—
- Only three?
- I was just like,
“What am I watching here?”
- I know.
- What’s the point of this movie?
- [Karrueche:] Listen, there is a
market for fans who LOVE shark-related movies.
- [Victor:] There are.
- [Serge:] I know.
- There’s a whole Shark Week.
- I know, but not three heads.
I know, I know I mean, not three.
You can pick two.
- I think there’s, like, a five-head shark movie now.
- [Serge:] Yeah, five?
- [Karrueche:] I think so.
- [Serge:] Oh, wow.
- [Victor:] That’s crazy.
- But it was the beginning of my career,
- Takin’ it to a new level now.
and it was my first lead role so—
- [Serge:] OK.
you know, you gotta start somewhere.
- Pay your dues. You gotta pay your dues, right?
- [Serge:] To me—
- [Karrueche:] It’s on Netflix, so—
- It’s on Netflix, yeah. I saw that. I said—
- Y’all can watch it.
- [Serge:] How did you get into “Claws”?
- [Karrueche:] How did I—
- Yeah, how did everything start?
- Um, it
came through as an audition, through my agents.
And then I got the call that I got it.
And I was like—
- You was pretty rachet in that
movie, huh? That role.
- In the show, yeah. Mhmm.
- Are you like that in real life? She’s like that in real life,
or just in the show?
- I think it comes out in certain occasions,
um, but—
- Just a lil’ bit.
- [Victor:] But overall—
- Every time I see you, you’re kinda, like, quiet, relaxed.
- Yeah. My real life is, like, right in between that.
In between Virginia and being, like, quiet.
- And you’re being messy in that movie too.
- Yeah. Very.
- Extra messy.
- [Karrueche:] Ex-stripper.
Killed some people. I shot some people.
- [Serge:] Yeah.
I’m gonna be honest with you—
- [Victor:] She loves that though, by the way.
- [Karrueche:] I love it.
- [Serge:] You love that?
- [Karrueche:] It’s my alter ego.
How do you feel about getting shot in Season 2?
- I loved the idea of getting me shot—
of getting me shot? Of me getting shot.
- Yeah, and it was cool. And I
had, like, all this blood and stuff.
And we had, like, a little stunt that I had to do.
I enjoyed getting shot.
[Laughing]
- Are you better at football than Victor at acting?
- Than Victor is in acting?
- [Victor:] Hmmm.
- [Serge:] Yeah.
[Laughing]
- Um...
I’mma just say yeah.
- [Serge:] Yeah?
- [Karrueche:] Yeah.
- I’ll give her that. I’ll give her that.
I mean, I haven’t had much acting prowess.
- He hasn’t—yeah, he hasn’t had—
- I mean, I was in “Ballers.” I did some things.
- [Karrueche:] Ballers, yeah
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So more hosting than, than other things.
- [Serge:] Are you trying working on acting too?
- Yeah, I been takin’ some acting classes recently—
- [Serge:] You been taking some?
- And just tryna, uh, you know,
open up a different kinda—
- Different angle, you never know.
- A different angle. You never know. Try to be
doin' a little bit of everything, right?
- What, what do you be doing right now?
- I’m at ESPN now—
- [Serge:] ESPN.
- Doing some corresponding things with them on “NFL Live”
and “Get Up” and “First Take.”
- Focus more on football, right?
- I been tryna, like, talk, you know, tryna—
- [Serge:] Basketball.
- Make some basketball—
- [Serge:] I know you know basketball.
- [Victor:] Of course. I’m always—
- [Serge:] I know you know basketball, yeah.
- We always talk basketball.
- Always around, yeah. Always watchin’.
I know you know basketball.
- So I just try to,
you know—I gotta get in with football first
and then convince them to now move around.
- [Serge:] Convince them. OK.
- [Jordi:] Victor, what do you think
about Serge as a player?
-  Oh, Serge is a phenomenal player.
I mean, I’ve always—
- Especially watchin’ his game evolve
- Thank you, bro.
over the years, after watchin’ him for many years,
I think he’s definitely one
of the elite players in the NBA.
Not just from his shot-blocking ability,
but he’s improved his jump. Now I’m gettin’ into analyst mode.
You see what I’m doin’ here?
- [Karrueche:] That’s OK.
- [Victor:] He’s improved his jump
shot, which made him—
- [Serge:] Yeah.
- [Karrueche:] Do what you do.
- [Serge:] Show your skills now, bro.
Can you say something, like—
- [Victor:] Oh, now he’s like—
- This is something, like—I wanna hear the way you talk when you’re on ESPN, like—
- [Victor:] You want me to give you, like—
- [Karrueche:] You gotta do your posture.
- [Victor:] Gimme a topic.
- Talk about Raptors’ championship.
- The Raptors’ championship game?
- Yeah, what—so, Victor.
What do you think about the
Raptors this year?
- [Laughing]
- [Karrueche:] Wait, you gotta get in your analyst posture.
- [Serge:] Exactly, show your skills, bro.
- I’m already here. I’m already forearm down.
- [Serge:] Yeah.
- Well, the Raptors this year were a very impressive team.
Obviously after adding Kawhi Leonard, it gave
them a dimension that they didn’t have before.
A defensive player that can go out
there and guard anybody back there.
And then in the frontcourt with guys like yourself,
being the shot-blocking prowess that you have,
it’s hard for guys to score on teams like you
And you have a solidified point guard,
in Kyle Lowry, You got a court
general to bring the ball to you guys and make it happen.
- [Serge:] OK, OK. I see you.
I see you.
- Yeah, he got it!
- That deserves a round of applause.
[Applauding]
- [Serge:] He got it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So what is the best meal he cooked for you?
- Victor has never cooked for me.
- [Serge:] Are, are you—
- Wait, did you make eggs one time?
- I did make some scrambled eggs.
- [Karrueche:] No—
- [Victor:] With American cheese.
- Are you Boricua? You Boricua? You’re Boricua, right?
- I’m Boricua, yes.
- What kind of Boricua man are you?
- So the type of Boricua man that I was growin’ up—
- [Serge:] Yeah.
- Was one that was surrounded
by Boricua women, right?
- [Serge:] Women, yeah.
- So they cooked for the Boricua man—
- Spoiled.
Spoiled.
- That was also the only child
for eight years and the only boy in
the family, so I was pretty spoiled.
But I make a mean scrambled eggs and
pancakes and French toast and stuff.
- Never had your pancakes or your French toast.
I don’t think you made scrambled eggs for me before.
- It’s gettin’ hot. Is it hot?
- It’s hot here. It’s hot, yeah.
- OK.
- [Laughing]
- Can you do the nails?
Like, the way you be doing on your show?
- On the show?
Um, I could do a lil’ somethin’ somethin’.
- I mean—
- I wish I’d have did that. I should have, like,
BeDazzled your nails.
- [Serge:] Oh, yeah?
- [Karrueche:] I should have painted—
- No, don’t worry. I’mma give you something to do it.
It’s coming.
- OK.
- [Victor:] Uh oh. This is—OK, all right.
- [Serge:] OK, it’s coming.
- [Karrueche:] Ohhh.
- Now it’s the fun part start. It’s coming.
- Oh, no.
- OK.
Food’s here.
- Lovely silverware, by the way.
- [Serge:] Yes.
How hungry are you guys?
- [Karrueche:] Very.
- [Victor:] Starving.
- [Karrueche:] Starving
- [Victor:] Very hungry, yeah.
- Very? Because today I cooked...
alligator claws.
[Sound of alligator growling]
- What, what is this, man?
- Oh, my God.
- This thing still alive in here, man?
- [Serge:] No, it’s not alive. I cooked that.
- Cooked what?!
It just twitched.
- This is alligator—alligator hands.
And after we done, you’re gonna paint the nails.
- You want me to paint that?!
- Yes. Please.
- [Karrueche:] Serge.
- [Serge:] His nails.
- Why can’t I paint your nails?
- No, because he got better nails than me. Look.
You see how it look?
- But we don’t eat that part anyway. We eat—
what part are we eating?
- [Serge:] Yes, we don’t eat that part.
- I’m gonna cry.
- [Serge:] Yeeeah. Nice.
- So you got sauce here if you guys want sauce.
- [Karrueche:] Is that fish sauce?
- [Serge:] OK, yeah.
- It’s called nuoc mam.
- [Serge:] Nic mam?
- [Karrueche:] No. Nuoc.
- [Serge:] Nock.
- [Karrueche:] Nuoc mam.
[Laughing]
- [Serge:] You said “nock mam.”
Well, I just, I just made that sauce because of you
because—
- No, it’s, it’s bomb. It’s good.
- You know I always do my research
before my guests come here.
- [Victor:] Yeah, tell me about it.
- [Karrueche:] OK, I like that.
- [Serge:] So you say “nic mam.”
- Nuoc mam.
- [Serge:] Nock.
- Nuoc.
Nuoc.
- [Serge:] Nic.
- N—
[Laughing]
- [Victor:] Close enough, close enough.
- [Karrueche:] Sure, yeah.
- [Serge:] Close enough, yeah.
- This is—oh, I just turned
and the nail did somethin’.
- [Offscreen:] You guys have knives?
You can eat it like a chicken wing.
- I have to pick this up?
- [Offscreen:] Yeah, yeah, pick it up.
- No, no, no. You want me to shake his hand
before I eat it? Is that what we’re doin’?
[Laughing]
- [Serge:] Bro, we gotta shake his
hand.
- [Verge:] What?!
- [Serge:] All right, you got the sauce here.
- [Victor:] Look at her!
She’s not even—[laughing].
- [Serge:] Let’s go.
- [Victor:] See, got a little piece.
- [Serge:] There you go, Vic. Like chicken,
yeah. Just try it.
- [Victor:] Let’s see. Let’s give it a shot.
- [Serge:] Ah, you see?
- It’s not bad.
- It’s not bad, right?
- The rice is phenomenal.
- [Victor:] Wait, I’mma get a little here.
That’s why I don’t like chicken sometimes,
because it looks like that!
- [Serge:] You have to try it, and then you can see.
- [Victor:] Yeah, a little bit of rice—
- [Karrueche:] No!
- [Victor:] Hold on, hold on. I got you.
- [Karrueche:] No, no,
no, no!
- I got you. You gotta mix with the rice.
- I’m gonna start crying! Leave me alone!
- [Serge:] There you go.
- [Victor:] Don’t panic out on me!
- [Serge:] You have to try it. It’s good.
- [Karrueche:] No! Oh, my God.
- [Victor:] It’s the smallest piece!
Here we go. I gotta do the hand, like—
- [Karrueche:] Dip it in the sauce first!
- [Serge:] OK.
- [Victor:] There she is.
[Applauding offscreen]
- [Victor:] It’s not bad!
- [Laughing]
- I ate it, OK?
- [Serge:] You see? It’s not that bad.
It’s good, right?
- [Victor:] Not that bad.
- [Serge:] All right, good job.
- But why you gotta keep the claws on it?!
- [Serge:] Thank you. That’s it.
- [Victor:] The claws.
- [Serge:] Now, like I say—
- Oh, yes.
- [Serge:] It’s time to do the nails.
- [Karrueche:] I got alligator stuck in my teeth.
See, you gotta get the perfect amount
of polish so it’s not too much.
- This how you do on your, on your show?
- [Karrueche:] Yeah.
- [Victor:] Is this the world’s first,
first alligator manicure?
- [Serge:] Nice. Oooh, smooth!
- OK, do that one red.
- [Serge:] OK, that one. And next—
- Do the other one pink.
- [Serge:] OK.
- [Karrueche:] And then we gonna do your nails.
- [Serge:] Mine? No.
- [Karrueche:] Yeah.
Oh, ughhh!
- I like that! You see that? She did it.
She’s good at it.
- [Karrueche:] Claws.
- [Serge:] All right. Thank you.
[Applauding]
What do you think about next season in general?
- I’m excited for next season,
mainly because there’s more parity in the league now.
Just to see, obviously, Kyrie and, and KD in Brooklyn,
Paul George and Kawhi in, in L.A.,
LeBron and Anthony Davis with the Lakers.
Russell Westbrook and James Harden in Houston.
I mean, the list goes on, you know what I mean?
- The Raptors still the champ, baby.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Serge:] We are still the champ.
- You guys are still the ones to beat.
- You’re a champion too, babe.
- All right, sports talk.
[Laughing]